In this video, we're
going to take a look
at how the social contract
issues have been addressed
around the world.
It turns out there's quite a
bit of experience with this,
sometimes with success for
a limited period of time
and sometimes without
as much success.
So let's see how other
countries address these issues.
Let's start with Australia.
Australia has a long history.
In the 1980s, a
new prime minister
came along by the
name of Bob Hawke.
And he came into office
negotiating a new labor
agreement called the accord,
with the labor movement,
where he was saying to labor,
if you limit your wage increases
to the price increases that
are happening in the country,
we will then find
some offsetting things
that we can do in
social welfare.
So they negotiated a
national health insurance.
They negotiated a
national pension program.
They put in place a variety
of other worker adjustment
programs.
And for business,
they allowed over time
much more flexibility in
promoting collective bargaining
at the level of the firm.
That worked for quite a while.
New prime minister comes
in from a different party,
says no more of this.
And so it hasn't really
continued up until today.
But now, in recent
years, Australia
has taken a more
modern approach.
It says today's workforce
needs flexibility
for more parental leave
so that women and men can
take care of their family
and work responsibilities.
So in 2011, their first
parental leave program
was put in place at
a national level.
Now they're struggling
to make that work
and to fight those
who want to repeal it,
but it is continuing to
play an important role.
Like Australia, Britain
has a long history.
In the 1980s and
'70s, like Australia
they were trying to
limit wage increases
to deal with inflation.
And then in the
1980s, along comes
Margaret Thatcher as a new Prime
Minister, called the Iron Lady.
And she says no more of that.
I'm going to take a hard line.
She took on the
most powerful union
in the country, the miners'
union in 1984 and 1985.
And she basically broke
a strike of that union
and started to bring down
the rate of wage increase
and help companies get more
flexibility and limited labor's
power.
That carried forward
up until the election
of another new Prime Minister,
Tony Blair in the 1980s.
And Tony Blair
basically said, I'm not
going to go back to
the old labor policies,
but I'm also not going to
continue the Thatcher approach.
We're going to try a third way.
And he looked at the
workplace issues that
were relevant for
his point in time
and he said, let's negotiate.
Let's put in place a commission,
a labor, business, government,
academic commission to
set up a minimum wage
so that we can help those
at the bottom of our income
distribution.
And that's the most
successful part of his legacy.
Well, if you really want to look
at the longest history of labor
management consultation
and cooperation,
you have to go to continental
Europe-- countries
like Sweden, Denmark,
France, Germany, sometimes
Italy and others.
In Sweden, for example
there's a long history
of business, labor, and
government negotiating
in a cooperative way, both
at the national levels
and more recently at the local
and regional levels and company
levels.
Basically, it's all part of
the social democratic values
of the Swedish and
Nordic societies saying,
we need to work together to
promote democracy and equity
in our economic policies.
And so that policy
continues today, even
in times of difficulty.
We'll take another look at
another country, Denmark.
Denmark in recent
years has recognized
the real issue is,
how do we adjust
from an industrial
to a more dynamic,
innovation-based economy?
That means firms
need more flexibility
to hire and fire and lay off
people as the economy changes.
And so Denmark has
traded off what they
call flexibility for security.
That is, firms are more open
and free to lay people off.
But there's an active
labor market policy
that then supports workers
as they make the transition
to new jobs, with a
stronger safety net,
with training, and with
adjustment and assistance.
So that then helps firms to
maintain their flexibility
and to adapt to changing times.
So around the world, we see a
variety of different approaches
to these issues.
Japan is another country
with a long history of labor
management consultation.
For years, its Ministry
of International Trade
and Industry worked
with business and labor
at the national level in
lots of consultation to say,
here is basically
the wage target
for increasing wages this year.
And then individual companies
and enterprise unions
would use that
target to negotiate
their specific conditions.
And that worked
quite well for Japan
and for business and labor in
that country for many years.
But then as the economy
changed and Japan
began to get competition
from China and other places,
it broke down.
And now China is
trying to figure out
how to get wages moving
more aggressively
and prices increasing, because
it's having trouble adapting
to a more dynamic economy.
Another example, a
very different example,
would be in Korea.
Korea has had a very tumultuous
labor management history.
Up until the mid-1980s, unions
were suppressed in Korea.
And there were often
violent strikes
that would come and
then get suppressed
and the police would come in.
And it would all die down
for a while and be quiet.
But then in 1987,
the government began
to open up the labor market
to stronger worker rights.
And it said, let's
try to work together.
But that long
history of conflict
made it very, very difficult
for labor and management
to work together.
And so even today, we
now see big protests
happening in Korean workplaces
as the government tries
to get Korean employers
to be more flexible.
And Korean workers
are saying, we
are not sharing in all of the
prosperity of this country.
Another example
would be in China.
Perhaps there's no
country that more needs
a new social
contract than China.
As we all know, as the
Chinese economy began
to open up to more
private enterprise
and foreign investment, we saw
a wave of strikes in China,
first at Honda in
2010, a big strike that
resulted in a wage increase.
And we've seen that
carry over in strikes
at one of Apple's big suppliers
of parts for computers
called Foxconn, where not
only workers are striking,
but sometimes they
commit suicide
in protest of the
conditions that they face.
So China doesn't really have
institutions and policies
to govern workplace
negotiations.
It badly needs to find a way
to allow workers to express
their needs, their interests,
their voice at the workplace
and at the same time maintain
what they call tranquility
in their relationships.
But it's very difficult.
Today, perhaps
too often, we find
that not only are these
spontaneous worker
protests occurring,
but they often
take the plant manager hostage.
So here's a picture
of an American
who has a plant in
China who's actually
waving from inside his office
to people on the outside,
because the workers
are saying to him,
you're not paying fair wages.
We need to negotiate
a better arrangement.
So around the world we
see these differences.
We see in Singapore, for example
a much better labor management
relationship, because there the
government takes a strong hand,
controls a lot of
economic policy.
But it does so with what
we would call a high road
strategy.
It invests in training.
It encourages firms to have
good labor management relations.
It's controlled
the labor movement
so that there aren't
as many strikes.
This is controversial,
because it's
not quite the democratic
society that we would want.
But it's the way in which
they do it in Singapore.
If we turn to South
America, countries
have had a more difficult time.
There, they've had on
and off approaches,
again often with dictatorial
governments controlling labor
and management
activities, but now
opening up to more
democracy but having
tremendous problems with price
increases and labor protests.
And then finally, I think we
can see some countries where
organizations act on their own.
So in Brazil, for
example, some companies
are taking their own approach
to developing a social contract
and not waiting for the
government to take action.
Well, what lessons can we
learn from all of this?
I think there are two.
First, it often takes a crisis.
A crisis will lead the
parties to pull together,
whether it's the
end of World War II
or whether it's a deep
financial crisis in Asia
or some kind of
other natural crisis
that might occur, perhaps from
climate change or whatever.
So crisis often helps parties
to set aside their differences.
And for a while, they can
work together and forge
a new set of agreements.
The second thing to remember
is that timing is everything,
that one has to take
advantage of specific events.
And when they occur,
like a financial crisis,
maybe you can renegotiate
pensions in an appropriate way,
or you can deal with problems
of recalcitrant unions
or recalcitrant
employers and find
ways to get them
to work together
because there's a specific
issue that they both confront.
So timing is
everything, using crisis
as an opportunity for change.
So all around the world,
workers, employers,
governments, educators
need to figure out
when it's possible to
negotiate a new social contract
and what are the issues that
are current and relevant
to our times.
Every country in the world
needs to address these issues,
because we have serious
problems in our workplaces
that need to be addressed.
And so we're very interested.
What are your thoughts?
What's most important
in your country?
What issues should the parties,
with your help, be addressing?
We look forward to
getting your thoughts
on this in our discussions.